hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back you beautiful people to
let's play mad father okay enough of the
theatrics we got work to do and not
enough time to do it so let's go let's
go let's go let's go alright so we've
got a lamb with which we can go down
into the basement at least that's what
I'm assuming and good old doggie doggy
over there is still munching away at his
meal so I'm gonna go down here and try
to see if I can't hello there we go okay
thank you very much for cooperating a
little lady it's [ __ ] lag oh the lamp
oh okay all right that's not good that's
not enough light that's that that vent
it's not enough light lady girly a hole
in the wall I couldn't fit in there well
try try little girl
hila barrels okay is that all that's
down here nothing really I thought for
sure I thought for a certainty dirt
indeed seriously what's up with this
corpse yes
all right that's enough disrespecting
the dead okay I don't know what was
going on there come on come on let's go
we gotta go we gotta go something else
here that I may have missed not sure if
I like oh yeah burning a bell lamp in
oil
can I throw the oil on them which I do
whooping yeah burn them all away by
throwing this oil and using the don't
know I don't know go this way
that's not away okay don't go that way
little girl you're almost dying maybe I
got to go back to some other area with
moms per fumet and I might be able to
use it
where's that kid kid kid yeah Matt
louder Jackson is messing I'm stuck
already well it was about time I had
been going so smoothly up until this
moment then of course ooh that weird
guy's gone hello mr. rabbit snowball
wait no yes aah the hole in the wall
just got to get snowball fast your
snowball come here snowball of fathers
who don't you run one way come on little
guy
- you go boy snowball Oh flashback time
what do I do and your legs hurt - I'm
worried stub ah where did you get - I
was so worried when you disappear I
couldn't wrap up that wound with you
running around wait huh
the wounds healed whoa water troubles
from rabbit father I try not to let
snowball out here sigh boy you the
rabbit made a mess of the kitchen sorry
snowball must have been trying to get a
bite of Mario's cooking again huh did
you find snowball father yes and healed
that leg wound while I was at it good
thing father's around hah snowball thank
you Father
snowball as a member of the family
treated as well as any other all right
but they began girl is it really time
for these you know flashbacks
I'm not good let's go save father
together got snowball just put them in
my pocket a box full of memories okay I
don't think there's anything else here I
need to take snowball down into the
basement and then shove them in a dark
hole in the ground and hope for the best
that's what I'm gonna do snowball thanks
for trusting me you're a member of the
family you're good on that hole get in
the hole ok enough ridiculous that dog
will not stop eating okay
alright snowball get in there snowball
maybe snowball could get in there
snowball
snowy oh I gotta actually use snowball
come on snowball please pretty please
just go in the dark hole
oh I'm snowball oh all right then can I
open the door I don't like this
snowballs in here all alone that's not a
good thing
ah-ha lighter oil another double
snowball ran away
I blame snowball did I lose snowball
lost snowball well you didn't seem all
that worried about it but I got
hi oh no I'm not good okay so I gotta go
down I'm gonna save first where's the
damn crow put the damn bird get back
here
all right stupid bird all right itself
go down here let it uh what de valor'
Maul daughter of murder oh there was a
bird here I didn't know okay well that's
not weird at all let's go burn some some
bitch's alive how about we do that can't
you through here what should i do should
burn them alive with this super-awesome
lighter oil use it I must be missing a
component yeah I can burn it with
lighter oil whatever I guess I needed an
ignition source what do I do now or
maybe I missed something in here there
were a few doors I guess it's very
possible I could have missed something
flames burn fiercely how about you light
lighter oil on fire here and then give a
Molotov cocktail to those guys over
there
maybe there's something over here like a
torch that I could build
duck firewood nope okay I'm hang in the
bucket there's a hole in the bucket so
it's totally useless well this is where
the story ends I thought I conquered one
Avenue a bit high
okay okay can't go in the toilet right
okay still not certain what need do kind
of that loss again I've already been
there it's got to be something on the
top floor that I missed over to the left
here because I haven't been in there in
a while
ergo aha what do we got here got a
pendant all right what do I do with said
pendant well why do I do with that whoa
whoa was with the Babu okay let me check
these other books just to make sure
there's nothing here that I don't need
actuary X this is a nightmare how could
this have happened
I killed a bird just like just like what
I saw that you can't hide these detail
from me I see them
you guys saw that book over there flip
right I can't get over there so I guess
that's just a lost cause locked gotta be
some here some where did that corpse go
it went somewhere I know that I know it
did okay there's nothing behind there
I've already counted the dolls from the
doll room maybe I could give the pendant
to one of these things you want a
pendant fifty bucks and it's yours
anybody want a pendant got a pendant pen
and aunt and aunt
anybody want a pendant zom zoms you want
a pendant whatever
I'm super stuck someone want a pendant
there's nothing here oh [ __ ] I'm stuck
good Oh snowball came back up here
snowball is relaxing yeah no joke okay I
don't think if I seen the picture of mom
no I don't know I'm thoroughly lost a
hand I'm not gonna waste time with this
well we'll be back just as soon as I'm
able to figure this out so stick with me
for a second here we go aha okay
cool I can move this don't know what
this does maybe I need to reach this no
that was wrong
crap I think I screwed up but I'm on the
right track here hang on let me see if
this resets it is it reset okay so where
do I need to take this to the top of
okay left left left left left left
no ah gimme gimme gimme gimme yeah I got
a cutting knife whoa whoa whoa how do I
do with a cutting knife was there a box
they needed to be cut was there
something that needed to be cut
Oh to cut a line it was a line here get
some string no do I gotta use it and I'm
not the right track
nope okay um do something can I defend
myself with that now ah
empty lighter happier don't light it
with oil sweet I'm gonna burn those
suckers alive go learn today I learned
about the secrets of fire okay so I take
the I take the lighter oil and I take
the lighter I've already got oil which
means I might be able to burn those
suckers to the ground now hopefully
freakin weirdos damn dog why do you need
to be like that oh they're not down here
what am i doing I'm an idiot you're not
down there I didn't even need to come in
here I'm just I'm so terribly stupid
those guys remind me of the thing from
Zelda the weird corpse II could kind of
thing he's you know get ready for a big
old pile of murder here like you suckers
on fire Burnham oh yeah
Burnham saw it light it light it up do
it do it lady do it do it
it burns oh yeah that brew that wasn't a
good thing to do why you needed to do it
you needed to do it man you needed to do
it you needed to do it little girl
nothing could have been done about it
you needed to get through there I think
I think just the charred remains all
right we're almost to the lab I don't
know how long this game is but hopefully
it's not gonna be over in like two
seconds hurry uh mistress you're wounded
ah but I will be fine
forget me escape somewhere safe it is
dangerous here where's father I heard
him scream from my room I must save the
doctor you just now realize this oof you
can't go with that wound but Maria what
happened to father the doctor is further
in his wife she uh what do you mean
Maria Maria Maria my it seems she passed
out good you again
you again om at any rate it sounds like
your father is gone on
deeper into the underground maze what
did Maria see mom passed away right
what's going on here don't tell me the
curse you'll only be able to confirm
your suspicions by pressing on won't you
yeah okay be a little more creepiest
stupid red-eyed betta crap what a weird
guy I couldn't agree more
a big sack yeah
filled with blood blood soaks through
the sack filled with unknown things most
likely blood and body parts it stinks of
blood hang there was uh another thing
out here that I'm gonna check out before
I go this way taxidermy room lined with
all sorts of strange got wood bucket
yeah my favor strange tools skulls okay
same thing still gross Oh goody-goody a
bottle of goo eyeballs got the eyeball
bottle is that all that I needed here
that all that I came for the wooden
bucket in the eyeballs all right I'm off
to a great start here okay I'm all out
of time for this part this game is weird
let's kick this weird man but I love it
I really do like these games I mean I do
regret a long time ago bad-mouthing him
in the first place so I'm gonna keep
playing it till thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos if I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
Oh
they need to definitely fix the sound in
this game
this is besides a body bag with
raishin logo